Doctor, you you hit on uh the third
leading cause of death in the United
States, and I'm sure most of us could
figure it's either heart related or
cancer or uh uh diabetes, things like
that. Can you clue us into what that is
and why?
Uh yeah. Okay. And thank you for asking
that because this is the 10,000 pound
gorilla in the room that nobody's
talking about. The third leading cause
of death as published in the Journal of
the American Medical Association is MD
directed treatments. This means you go
to a medical doctor, an MD, he gives you
a treatment and you die from it.
According to the United States
Department of Health and Human Services,
15,000
Medicare patients a month are killed by
MD treatment and nobody goes to jail. A
handful of terrorists fly two planes
into the Twin Towers. 3,500 people die
and we go to war, but 15,000 people a
month are killed by medical doctor
treatments and we don't bat an eyelash.
This is because
we have been
I don't want to say brainwashed, that's
not the correct term, but we have been
for the last hundred years
um
kind of led into this false belief. You
know, I think it was Marcus Welby that
started it, that the medical doctor is
king and knows everything about
everything. And really, you need to just
shut up and follow your medical doctor's
advice. Most people in the United States
have no idea at all of the history of
the evolution of medicine in the United
States. In the early 1900s, it was a
relatively level playing field between
the chiropractors, the osteopaths, the
homeopaths, and the MDs. In 1915 1920
there was something called the Flexner
report. The Carnegi Corporation funded
this man named Abraham Flexner. He went
all around the country and he went on
stage coach and train and horseback.
This was before the interstate highway
system, right? Took Flexner five years
to do this. He went all around the
country and did an inventory of all of
the medical schools that prescribed
drugs.
He brought the list back to the Cargis
who own drug companies. And then the
Cargis and the Rockefellers gave
millions of dollars of free money to the
medical schools and hospitals in the
United States that were prescribing
drugs.
That was the beginning of the end. After
the Flexner report, there was no more
level playing field in the United
States. And the MDs started a juggernaut
that's taken off. Most people in the
United States think that the predominant
medicine here, MD directed
pharmaceutical medicine, we think that
those guys are top dog because their
therapeutics are better than the
homeopaths or the naturopaths or the
chiropractors. It's not. They're in the
driver's seat because of political and
financial coalitions that were built at
the turn of the century that most people
have no idea of at all. And it's a
gigantic
problem. And I I mean it's crazy, right?
It's the third leading cause of death.
And yet when the government makes noise
about messing with people's insurance,
everybody freaks out.
And that's a whole another thing to talk
about, isn't it? Because what is medical
insurance? When you buy medical
insurance, what are you doing? You're
betting that you're going to get so sick
you will not be able to afford it.
Mhm.
Right.
Yeah.
Right. And then so you pay good money
every month to gain access to a system
of medicine that's the third leading
cause of death in the United States.
We need our heads examined quite
frankly. That's why we give Dr. Wallik
and myself collectively we give 400 free
lectures a year and we're building a
grassroots network because people don't
know this. I mean people I come to my
lectures and they look at me and say
couch potatoes live longer. medical
doctors are the third leading cause of
death. You know what's going on here?
We're like we're like the people uh you
know in Galileo's time saying, "Hey
everybody, you know that's the sun
that's at the center of the solar
system, not the earth." Well, hey
everybody, the earth is round. It's not
flatter. Hey everybody, slavery is a bad
thing,
right? This is a we're we're a social
agenda here. Why do we have a social
agenda? because people are suffering
needlessly.
You wouldn't believe as God is my
witness. You would not believe the
things that I've seen people recover
from in holistic medicine.
It's the body's ability to fix itself is
remarkable. And most of the time, all
that the body needs to do that is the
raw materials that it needs to do that.
And we need to stop eating food that's
hurting the body.
You know, if you put diesel fuel in an
unleted engine, even if it's a brand new
Ferrari, it's going to run like crap if
it runs at all. There's nothing wrong
with the car. It just had the wrong
fuel.
It's the same with the human body. You
give the human body the raw materials
that it needs, clean up the diet,
Superman,
Superwoman.
And you know, if you don't get to super
status, then at least your blood
pressure normalizes, at least your
arthritis goes away, at least your
anxiety and panic attacks go away, and
you can sleep through the night.